les protéines servent entre autres à
reconstituer la fibre musculaire
influence euse de 23 ans ni la dispose
d'une communauté de onze mille abonnés
cette diététicienne à son compte depuis
deux ans et spécialisé en nutrition du
sport elle propose des consultations en
présentiel et en visioconférence son
objectif accompagner les gens vers de
meilleures habitudes alimentaires c'est
une branche qui est dans le paramédical
donc et dans l'entré deux le partage et
le côté humain en fait on apprend en
fait les bases d'une alimentation en
jean et finalement avec la société
actuelle on a complètement perdu en fait
ces bases avec la société de
consommation alors j'ai fait une
alimentation en quatre repas par jour tu
veux avoir un petit déjeuner un déjeuner
une collation et un dîner qu'on voit
vraiment du coup l'évolution de la
personne l'accompagnement de la personne
et c'est ça qui est le plus beau en fait
voilà personne évoluer et être heureuse
en fait comblé
entre deux consultations nena sadhana
une toute autre activité les réseaux
sociaux notamment instagram elle est ce
que l'on appelle une influence euse
actif depuis un peu plus de trois ans sa
communauté grandit de jour en jour et la
suite dans son quotidien le milieu de la
décennie que c'est un milieu qui est
assez fermé il n'y a pas énormément
d'emplois
donc je me suis dit il faut pas attendre
des diplômés pour aller du coup chercher
de l'emploi autant partager déjà demandé
ce que j'apprends voilà mon compte
instagram donc on est là on retrouve les
trois parties où est la partie du coût
recettes alimentation la partie sport et
la partie du coût lifestyle classer les
fameux story où je partage vos laleu-la
style
là que j'étais en train d'aller
travailler là ce que je mange voilà qui
permet du coup aux gens de savoir à peu
près comment du coup et qu'il aurait
l'alimentation etc c'est plus au niveau
des consultations que
que je gagne ma vie la partie du coût
rémunération par publicité instagram sur
par exemple une marque de chaussures une
marque de vêtements que ça c'est quand
même un peu plus compliqué d'avoir de
gagner sa vie foncièrement avec sa
points et le les habits j'espère que
vous allez bien aujourd'hui je vous
annonce du coup qu'on va lancer un f1 q
n'hésitez pas à me poser toutes les
questions que vous avez sur
l'alimentation sur le sport sur le
bien-être sur mon parcours sur ce que je
propose en tant qu diététicienne je
cherche à partager du coup la notion que
la diététique la nutrition la bonne
alimentation alimentation saine c'est
pas aussi compliqué que ça en a l'air et
justement normaliser les choses est
passé du coup par ces réseaux sociaux
c'est déjà une première porte avant tout
ce qui est les journaux la télévision et
c'est un second métier qui n'a pas que
des avantages
c'est quand même du travail c'est à dire
qu'on doit être c'est régulier en droit
poster régulièrement que ce soit du coup
ils postent des vidéos les stories donc
c'est un travail de tous les jours c'est
à dire que même si on part en vacances
on pense à ce qu'on va poster et obtient
on va prendre un café bastien pour moi
en photo donc c'est vrai que c'est une
partie du coup c'est dans notre
quotidien quoi avant de trois ans cette
double casquette profite pleinement à
nina ses patients et ceux qui la suivent
sur les réseaux sociaux elle compte bien
développer encore plus ses deux
activités complémentaires dans les
années à venir